-We thought to ourselves,
"Who can we book for a live show
that's on at 12:37 at nigh
who's not going to be tired?
-Exactly.
-Terry Crews.
-That's right, man. First of
all, I took my pre-workout
I'm about to go straight
to the gym right after this.
It's all good, man.
I usually wake up about 3:00
to go to the gym,
so it's perfect.
-You're hosting
"America's Got Talent."
-Yes.
-As a host, how do you think
you would do hosting something
like the debates tonight?
-Oh, my God. You know what
I would literally
liven the sucker up, man.
I'd be like,
"Come on, Elizabeth Warren
Tell them what you got!
It's a cage match!"
-Yeah. Little more energy.
-You know what?
I would make them arm-wrestle.
You know what I mean?
They would basically be
wrestling each other.
It would be a lot of games
a lot of punching in the face.
"Boo. Take that."
-At the very least, I feel lik
if you start with 10,
it should end with 8.
-Exactly.
Somebody should not survive.
-Yes.
-And that would keep everybody
right into it.
-You love competition.
Or at least you love
watching competition.
But you're not
a competitive person.
-I hate competition.
You gotta understand.
I believe competition
is the opposite of creativity.
Man. It's ridiculous to me
Listen. I was in the NFL.
I did the whole --
The entertainment thing is all
about competing with each other.
But one thing I've discovere
is that that whole thing
just leaves everybody broken
and bloody and the whole thing
I decided to just
kind of walk off,
do my own thing,
and stay creative,
and that is where
I found my goal.
-That's fantastic.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And yet you find yourself
hosting a competition.
-Yes. Well, America
wants blood, Seth.
-Yeah.
-You know? Listen.
First of all,
"America's Got Talent"
could easily be an exhibition,
but they want people to go home.
They want people to die.
-Yeah.
-This is why the whole thing
with the debate,
I would literally say
someone has to be killed.
"I'm so sorry.
I didn't vote on this."
-Were talent shows
something you did as a kid
-Listen. First of all,
you gotta understand.
Growing up in Flint, Michigan,
my mom --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes, my mom was very religious
I was not allowed
to go to the movies,
not allowed to listen
to secular music,
not allowed to play sports
Everything I do today,
I was not allowed to do.
So what was crazy is that
she wouldn't let me perfor
in a talent show,
so I begged and begged,
and she said, "No, no."
I said, "Well, can I host it?!
And she was like,
"Oh, damn. Okay."
And let me tell you, I hoste
my high-school talent show
and not knowing that
that would be my future,
that I would eventually grow u
to host the world's
biggest talent show,
it's serendipity.
-There you go.
I'm glad she gave her approval
[ Cheers and applause ]
You did not go straight
from the NFL to acting.
You had some time in between
And I read that you were
Ice Cube's security guard.
-You know, I was a security --
It wasn't even
Ice Cube's security.
I was like
Ice Cube's car security.
He would get out of the car.
"Hey, man. Watch my car.
Nothing better happen
to my car."
And I'm like, "All right.
Cool, man. I got you."
It wasn't sexy. It wasn't nice
I actually was security
on "Next Friday"
and ended up in
"Friday After Next."
Which was crazy.
I did the third movie.
Cube has been responsible
for so many careers.
And I just thank him
to this day.
-When you showed up
for "Friday After Next,"
did he remember you as the guy
who used to watch his car?
-You know, totally.
He was just like,
"Hey, man, you that dude
that used to watch the car."
But I'm going to tell you this
right now, though.
He watched me in "Training Day
as an extra.
"I really liked
'Training Day,' man,
the way you were standing there,
you know, muscles glistening
It was good, man.
I'll get you a part."
And so it all worked out.
It's so funny
'cause it's never changed.
Every time I see Cube,
I'm like, "Hi, sir."
I'm like, "Oh, damn."
Even though I'm acting,
I'm doing my thing,
he's still my boss
psychologically.
It's weird. It never changes
-Certain things never do.
I will tell you the same thing
The few times he's been here -
and he's just a lovely perso
to talk to --
but I kind of can't believ
I'm talking to Ice Cube.
-I know. I'm still in awe.
It's almost like I want to
watch his car everywhere I -
I'm going to watch it right now.
-I want to ask about
"Brooklyn Nine-Nine."
Congratulations. I'm so happy...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Obviously,
save for a few exteriors,
you mostly shoot in L.A.,
and now being out in New York,
do people recognize you more
Do they appreciate that
it's a show about Brooklyn
-First of all,
my daughter lives in Brooklyn,
and I make her take me place
so that I can get recognized
-Okay.
-It's like, "Hi!"
They're like,
"'Brooklyn Nine-Nine'!"
And I'm like, "Oh, yeah.
You know. Yeah, I do that show."
-Does your daughter
know what you're doing?
-Yeah, she does.
-She does.
-She's like, "No, Dad.
You need to stay inside."
I'm like, "No.
Can we go somewhere, please?
Let's just walk down
the street, please. Let's go."
-You deserve it!
-I know! Thank you!
-You deserve it.
-Thank you.
-Hey. Um, congratulations on
"America's Got Talent",
"Brooklyn Nine-Nine."
And thank you so much for
being here on the live show.
It's just always such
a pleasure. Terry Crews.